The domain is only going to contain values of x for which the function is
defined. Let's start off with the domain. The domain is just the set of inputs
over here, for which the function is defined. So, the only ones that actually
map two values over in the f of x oval are 1, 2, and 4. So, those values
together are the set that is our domain. Since 3 and 5 aren't actually paired
with anything, over here in f of x. In other words, if you plug these inputs
into the function, you won't get a output, they are not part of our domain. Now,
our range it's a set of values that the domain values map to. So that's going to
be 20 from the 1, the 2 maps to 80, and then 4 maps to 80 as well. But since 80
is already in the set, we don't repeat it. Now remember, this does still count
as a function even though there's a shared value in the range between two values
in the domain.